and that's the thing is like in 2022
women are bailed out of every single bad
decision that we make like every single
one we are bailed out so um for example
like they used to require women to be
virgins to get a ring we make the
decision to sleep around and we still
get ranks right that's one bad decision
or let's say we get pregnant you can get
bailed out of that bad decision because
you get an abortion or you can keep it
and you can still give it up for
adoption or you can keep it and you can
still get remarried typically where like
historically that you would have been
done for even if you weren't a virgin
like you would be done for and so you
have those like being bailed out of
those bad decisions on top of that woman
owned two-thirds of the Consumer Debt so
and all of the government programs are
typically women on them and they're men
paying for them so it's men always
bailing out women for poor decisions
that's interesting I was actually
talking to my dad about this well I he
kind of went out because he watched he
watched the podcast and um
you know
one thing that he kind of mentioned was
actually as women we probably have a lot
more like we have
oh because we're because we're emotional
as beings right it's like the longer
term impact of
these things that can happen the
consequences of it can have a lot more
of a long-term impact on women than it
can men because obviously women are more
emotional because what do you what do
you mean a long-term impact as in kind
of live life with you know stress
anxiety depression or you know
um feeling you know carrying that toxic
um behaviors in them or I'm just I just
don't can I have a specific example of
how it would affect men and women
differently okay so let's say for
example
um
a woman has a casual relationship and
then maybe Falls pregnant and then and
then decides to
you know maybe they developed an
emotional attachment with the the the
person but then the man doesn't for
example and then then she becomes
pregnant and then she has to choose
between whether she wants to
you know have a baby or not right so
that that would be like a that would be
an example so but the long term the
potentially because women are wired and
more emotionally the longer term impact
of making that decision and and actually
going through the consequences of that
of the consequences is more on the woman
no consequences more in wisdom but just
as I'm just saying like as in the action
and reaction like as in the as a result
of the ACT which happened so so the
actors you're talking about sex like
casual sex yeah someone's having casual
sex they fall in love and then the woman
has okay more longer term emotional
impact as a result yeah so let's say
then the father decides that they don't
want to be a part of that child's life
the mother chooses I'm gonna have this
child
um
then she may need that additionals as
you like to call it bailout
um then let's say opposed to men because
that woman's emotional
needs are different well but the thing
is like women are 100 in control of
birth men have no power and no say and
they're on the hook for child support
for 18 years
if they do if if she does have the kid
yeah so how you don't think it's
emotionally impacting someone when they
when they're taking up to in the U.S you
can get up to 50 of a man's income can
you imagine getting two thousand dollars
a month spending a thousand dollars on
your baby mama
you don't think that's I think that does
that can have
an impact on it's like Soul crushing it
can be and you know I'll be honest like
you know I was I dated someone who had
two two had two children you know and
I know that you know he went through a
really hard time just trying to be a
part of his children children's lives
you know and that that kind of
that does that does exist but and
obviously he was distressed because of
it but
I would say that
the I would say that it didn't really
emotionally I feel like the emotional
impact would have been a lot more on the
mother
than on the man
because we're instantially more
emotional
so so then what is that if a girls were
emotional wouldn't she not want to kill
the kid
what did killing the kid coming to
because you said we were talking about
that's why they would need the extra
bailout right that's what you're saying
Anthony
[Laughter]
um that is down to whether you believe
abortion is killing a child or not
and that is like subject to Yeah well
yeah I know but the whole the whole
point is like that like women have
rights in that situation and men don't
you see what I'm saying yeah I guess but
then it's
the woman's body
it's the woman's body right but it's
happening to them right the whole point
is it's his wallet right so so in this
case like women are 100 in control of
birth they're not they're not 100 in
control of who gets pregnant but they're
much more in control than men are right
yeah because we have 10 to 15 forms of
birth control yeah that we can use they
have one yeah but then if you think you
like
financially as well like men don't have
to pay if they don't they can go to jail
exactly they'll have the there's a
consequence to that but they still have
that choice like they don't have to pay
child but then that's what you're saying
there's a consequence in it and that's
what I was saying earlier you know women
have women yeah there's no consequence
for women do you understand there's no
that I just said no no I just said you
could you can get an abortion if you
want you know you can decide you know to
like adopt a kid give it up for adoption
you like there's so many you can there's
so many pills and and contraceptions
that you can take to avoid you know
these consequences and it jumps down
once the sperm leaves the man's body
that you know he's his life is basically
in your hand and people like to use this
this example of
um
consent to
sex is consent to having a child but
imagine if a man were to do the example
of oh this woman right now at the start
she consented to having sex with me but
I just carried on even though she didn't
want to people be like this guy needs to
get put in prison and you'll get four
years so the whole notion of consent to
sex but the babies come when has he
consented to that I think you consent to
a child as soon as you have sex but it's
like this dilute like you know and I
think but I think we have like where
contraception has given us this freed so
you're saying as soon as you have sex
you consent to a child so that means you
can send to ejaculation so if you if I
start sex with you now you want me to
stop because you've consented to
ejaculation there's nothing you can do
to stop me because you've consented
because that's the same logic
yeah I think you know at the end of the
day of two people are having unprotected
sex then sure
you're not getting one so what I'm
saying is you're saying is once you
consent to sex you consent to
ejaculation into the other person yeah
we've agreed on that because that's what
causes for a baby to be made yeah yeah
you risk that yeah yeah so if we've
consented to that if you now have sex
with a man and you want to stop he can
now say to you babes you've consented to
ejaculation so you're going to wait here
and you're going to hold every single
inch until I finish because that's what
you consented to is that what you're
advocating for hold every single inch of
what
because you've consented an ejaculation
and you run that risk so now he doesn't
want to stop
the same signal